foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Eric Normand
and today I'm going to talk about
functional programming and how you can
use it to improve testing reuse and
maintenance in your existing code base
regardless of if you're using a
functional programming language this
should apply no matter what okay so
today I hope you come away with a new
perspective on programming
that you can apply to your code new
skills for writing better software and
some curiosity to seek out more I'd like
to start with a little story back in
2013 I started a Meetup all about
functional programming with some friends
here in town and every month uh the
discussion would always go to one of
these basic questions about functional
programming the big one was what is
functional programming because we'd have
new people coming in all the time they
were curious
and so that was a big you know like
almost every time we talked about what
is functional programming
um I also had questions like why should
I care like I already know how to
program what why how will this help me
another question was should I just
rewrite everything in FP like is this an
All or Nothing thing
another question was well I already know
JavaScript can I just do FP and
JavaScript
or for that matter can I learn FB in
JavaScript
without having to like learn a new
language
and after these discussions
uh I felt like I had a pretty good grasp
on at least what I thought was important
to explain to people and to be able to
to teach what what we did as functional
programmers I've been programming in
functional languages for about 20 years
now it's not a very common thing and so
there I needed a lot of explanation and
people would ask me what should I read
what should I go do and I could not
recommend a book so I had to write it
myself so groking Simplicity is my
attempt to
uh take this idea of functional
programming that's been kind of stuck in
Academia at least in terms of How It's
discussed in books and give it to people
like from a perspective of practical
commercial software not Academia
and to do that
I had to come up with a perspective on
it that would allow me to teach it
without because I can't teach the whole
thing so I eventually wound up looking
at functional programming as a set of
skills if you look at this Venn diagram
on the left we have this orange circle
that is things non-functional
programmers too then the circle on the
right is the things functional
programmers do so these are different
skill sets there's a lot of overlap a
lot of the stuff that functional
programmers do you'll do you know
everyone will do
um but then there's some difference
and that difference is what needs
teaching and so that's what I focused on
in the book these are the things that
professional functional programmers do
that other like non-functional
programmers don't do and then I had to
come up with a linear order and kind of
organization scheme for how this is
going to work so I
I've discovered that there's really two
levels these levels kind of correspond
to uh your your your level as a
programmer uh but because the second
level requires the first one in certain
ways and the first one is actually like
necessary for the Paradigm so we're
going to start there and we're going to
go over both of these two levels uh
there's two parts of the book that the
that you know corresponds to the two
levels uh and we're going to start with
the first one
so part one
is all about distinguishing actions
calculations and data to my mind this is
a fundamental difference in functional
programming versus other ways of
programming uh functional programmers
distinguish these three categories so
we're going to go over what each of them
is and
um and then the next bullet we're gonna
look at how actions kind of spread
through our code and then lastly we're
going to do a refactoring to extract out
a calculation from an action
so let's get started with distinguishing
actions calculations and data so we can
imagine a code base we pluck some code
out of that code base
and we'll see stuff like this so the
first thing is a little bit of Json
uh it turns out to be a Json object then
there's this function called send email
there's a function called sum there's
save user DB string length get current
time and then this array of numbers
now I've starred three of these
functions
because they're different from the
others in that
it matters very much how many times I
call them or when I call them
so for instance send email if I call
that two times the email is going to get
sent twice
and I don't want that to happen so I put
a star next to it just to indicate it's
different whereas if I have some
I can sum the numbers as many times as I
want it's not going to affect the
outside world
right so you can imagine how send email
would be harder to test because you
might want to run send email
20 times to run 20 different tests and
now you have to deal with you know am I
actually sending these emails
likewise save user DB
it depends if you call it zero times
it's very different from calling it one
time and then get current time every
time you call it it's going to give you
a different time so this is uh these
these all get a star they depend on when
they are run or how many times they're
run
so functional programmers will put all
those starred functions above the line
and we'll call those actions okay that's
the term I came up with that I'm using
in these slides and in my book
uh this we'll talk about what functional
programmers generally call these later
but we'll call them actions for now so
now there's everything else under the
line
and there's a difference between just
bits of data and a function that you can
run
so we'll draw another line below the
line will be data and then above that
line between actions and data is
calculations so calculations are
actually things that you can run they're
functions or operations and you know
operators like addition or
multiplication that don't have an effect
on the outside worlds they're just
computations and then the data are inert
things so let's go over each one and
like
give precise definitions actions if you
look it up in the dictionary one
definition you might find is the process
of doing something typically to achieve
an aim and I think that that captures
what actions are all about they're
trying to do something uh external it's
not just thinking about it it's actually
doing the thing
we call them in FP jargon you might have
heard these terms before
impure functions effects or side effects
so this is the these are the terms that
you'll hear outside of these slides in
my book
um I use the term actions because
I think that these are misleading and
confusing uh when you're when you're a
beginner so for instance function is
both a like a mathematical concept and a
language feature and they're different
uh and then effect it's not a great term
because it's actually uh we're talking
about the cause so the cause of the of
the email being sent is
the function that's called send email
the effect is the actual email that
arrives in your inbox right
so it's not quite the effect it's the
cause but then cause isn't the right
word either I had to come up with my own
term okay and then there is a rule of
thumb for identifying them actions
depend on when you run them
or how many times you run them when you
run them that's like the order that you
run the actions in and then how many
times you run them that's repetition so
if you call it zero times one time two
times uh what happens there next we have
calculations dictionary definition is
computation from inputs to outputs in FP
jargon we're going to call them pure
functions or referentially transparent
functions again it's problematic because
in a lot of languages they are not
implemented as functions I mentioned
before the addition operator plus times
divide those are calculations they are
pure they don't have any side effects
they're not actions but they're not
functions either so I came up with this
term calculations
and they are
Eternal outside of time I mean imagine
addition it's never going to change any
machine you run addition on it's going
to give you the same answer
forever you know you can't imagine it
changing if it does change we'll be in
big trouble okay data facts about events
used as a basis for reasoning discussion
or calculation data is kind of the most
boring of them because they're inert but
I think they're actually quite
interesting in themselves they're
serializable they're self identical
meaning they are what they are which is
kind of interesting you know a function
is kind of opaque you don't know what
it's going to do really until you call
it whereas data you can read it but the
downside of data is that they require
interpretation so you need software to
to parse it and and make assumptions
about what it means in order to to use
the data so we're going to talk mostly
about actions and calculations because
data is not there's not as much to say
the big distinction is when you're
writing code so the thing is functional
programmers try to write way more
calculations than actions like more code
should be in your calculations and
actions basically as much as possible in
calculations actions only when necessary
why because actions depend on time and
it's just a pain to work with they're
much harder to deal with as we'll see
the thing is though that we pay much
more attention to actions we spend more
time with actions because they are
harder to work with this is kind of a
common misconception in functional
programming that we don't want to use
actions at all or that
um you know we we basically try to to
ignore them we actually spend a lot more
time and are a lot more attention making
sure that our actions run correctly
uh and I think we spend it more than
other uh paradigms so it's kind of
interesting that there's that kind of
Duality we spend more code on
calculations but then more attention on
actions to make sure they're right all
right we're going to talk about the
spreading rule let's imagine this
programmer uh has some code and
she can correctly identify that this
function called send payout is an action
we should go through what the code does
so down at the bottom there's the main
function and it calls affiliate payout
with the affiliates
affiliate payout is going to Loop
through all the affiliates
and then call figure payout for each one
and figure payout is going to multiply
the sales from the affiliate times the
commission and if they're owed more than
a hundred dollars it's going to send the
payout meaning it's going to contact the
bank and transfer money to their account
obviously send payout is an action it's
physically or you know it's it's
reaching out to another system and
sending money to them so if you call it
twice
it's it's a big deal you're you're
giving too much money but is the rest of
her code actions she claims it's only
got this one so let's apply the
spreading rule
and we'll learn it as we go so we'll
start with that one highlighted action
now one rule of the spreading rule or
one part of the spreading rule is that a
function that calls an action must
itself be an action because now if I
call figure payout twice well that's
going to send the payouts twice too so
figure payout also is an action because
that's an action we have to highlight
the place where it is called in the next
function
but again we can continue you know
recursively applying this rule
oh sorry you can't read that down there
we can continue recursively calling this
Rule and of course affiliate payout is
an action
because it called the action and so now
we have to highlight affiliate payout in
Maine
and then all right now main is a an
action and nothing calls main so we're
done but the thing is it's all actions
you have actions at the bottom of your
call stack you know the top of your
calls to everything under that
all the way to main is going to be
actions and so this is one of the
problems that functional programmers
have recognized in using actions in like
anywhere in the code is that they spread
they just spread all up until main so
you're going to have actions in your
code we we need to send that email like
that's what the software is supposed to
do we need to send payouts but we just
have to identify and be conscious
and mindful of where what is an action
so this spreading rule helps us see that
yes if you put action somewhere in there
it could spread all the way and infect
everything we'll talk about the problems
of actions in a moment uh first let's
talk about extracting calculations so
this is a refactoring that will let us
take some existing code that's a mixture
of actions and calculations maybe it's
it's one big action and extract out a
piece of it that could be a calculation
so here's a function called show total
uh it initializes total to zero then it
Loops through
the items
in in a for Loop right I am some Global
variable somewhere
and it's going to add the price of each
item to the total and then at the end
it's going to set the inner HTML
property of this Dom element to total so
it will show it in the web page we can
deduce a couple things
the first is that the red elements are
actions so let's start with items so
we're reading the value of a global
variable
and a global variable could change at
any time right calling show total when
items has 20 things in it is going to be
different from calling it when items has
10 things in it right so now show total
depends on when it is called
because it is reading items likewise
it is setting uh something in the Dom so
if we call it again I mean maybe this
wouldn't change the Dom because you'll
get the same total calling it two times
but if we called it zero times versus
calling it one time that would
definitely be a difference so that part
is an action but I've highlighted in
blue all this other stuff that's not
really an action in here this iteration
through the through the items array and
updating total adding to Total like all
that stuff does it's going to give you
the same answer if items were the same
this total is always going to be the
same so we can we can probably look at
this blue stuff and try to extract that
out as a calculation we do that we make
a function called sum total and it takes
items as an argument
and then we have this for Loop in there
now items in here is blue because it's
the argument it once it's passed in it's
not going to change
um because you know we can if we need to
sum a different array we can just pass
it in we don't have to assign it to a
global variable and then it's going to
return the total at the end and now show
total instead of having the for Loop in
line in there it's going to call sum
total and I made a mistake items should
be red because it is still reading from
the global variable so this items thing
should be read and then of course this
is unchanged
so notice we've built a calculation
called sum total we've moved a lot of
code out of this action and into a
calculation now let's go a little bit
deeper in what we actually did here
these two reads to items these are
actually implicit inputs to our function
they're implicit the explicit inputs to
a function are the arguments but these
are implicit inputs it's data entering
the function
that doesn't go through the arguments
and then we are setting the inner HTML
property modifying the Dom that's an
implicit output the explicit output
would be a return value from the
function so we have an implicit input
and an implicit output and we've
replaced them with explicit inputs and
explicit outputs at least in our
calculation right so this is the the
refactoring that we're trying to do
we're trying to identify how does data
enter into the function how does it
leave and only use arguments and return
values to do that and we could just
write it out like this replace implicit
inputs with arguments and replace
implicit outputs with return values